foreign
the three Muslims we're joined here with
myself brother Angel and Rami how you
doing boys
[Music]
look at that look at that quality on
Romney's pick bro
bro alone
actually let me comment on it because
people are gonna say that it's Kaza ah
bro come on bro don't admit to the
salafis bro no no no they're they're
right and let me let me explain because
I know someone's gonna say something
um long story short I said I cannot get
a skin fade and so I need it above that
and um this technically isn't a skin
fade but it still counts islamically
um but it was unintentional I asked a
person of knowledge and a friend of mine
if I should if I need to shave it and he
said no you don't need to because that
was not your intention and uh you could
just wait so I know someone's gonna
comment on it it was not intentional
um
policing himself bro so y'all can't say
anything today so everyone's wondering
you know where's Steph is Steph coming
today so unfortunately we had to
reschedule brother stuff is called but
inshallah we will get that done sometime
um smash that like button we almost have
500 stream viewers already from the love
we're gonna start around 600 or 700. a
very juicy topic today uh if you don't
mind doing a favor since um
can you remove all the things you added
because it might be choppy I'll just
share myself okay no worries um can you
point your your mic to more towards your
mouth
no that was the number bro that's better
it was just better I think he's the gain
or is it good I'd say increase maybe a
little bit increase a little bit let's
see
how's it no it's good I'll let you know
if it starts cutting okay so guys listen
all these comments here saying stuff
like this We're Not Gonna We're not
gonna go that far because at the end of
the day you guys know we already hosted
snico on a stream uh after he
disrespected Islam he mocked Salah the
Adan this is unacceptable he apologized
you addressed it
now whether his intention was damage
control and he wanted to come on a
stream with us and kind of clear his
name
that's not up to me to know only Allah
knows or whether his intention was
genuinely to learn about Islam be
educated on Islamic disrespect why we
have no chill bro when it comes to this
type of stuff we don't play games
Allah knows best
that's not all to us to judge someone's
sincerity but what is a parent is he is
not and I'm gonna say this that gets
clear as possible he is not qualified to
be talking about Islam
we don't even consider ourselves
Scholars we don't even talk about all
the topics we want to talk about because
some do more harm than good let alone
sneaker who's not a Muslim who has no
idea about Islam and what he is doing in
this podcast with two women and this
islamophobic guy who's like a complete
liptard like Destiny he's been making
videos about Islam for years now I think
that it's not a good thing that he
thinks that he's qualified to speak on
me so
um but before we go in on harami do you
guys have anything to add yeah I I just
I want to say let's let's this is for
everyone including people in the chat
let's you know chill with the insults
and the name calling and that stuff
let's not insult anyone
um when people speak ill of Islam and of
the Prophet saws not to respond in that
same way all right the Sunnah is to
respond either you know if
it depends on what they're saying but if
they're speaking falsehood then you have
to correct them politely and if they're
just insulting and name calling then
just walk away whatever let them sit
there in their Rampage and whatever
people are going to see this person's
just losing their mind but if they have
you know intellectual or rational
logical problems with Islam you engage
with them politely Allah says debate
kindly debate with them you know in the
Quran and we know the Hadith of
um the prophet Allah to someone he was
sitting people were insulting him
and the prophet were both silent Abu
Bakr just couldn't take it anymore he
got angry he started he stood up started
cussing them out back and forth walked
away
he walked away he's like I'm not going
to engage in this you know it's childish
all right he didn't say that but you
know kind of adding my own kind of
interpretation on there so let's let's
have the same practice you know Islam is
better than what they believe and
teaches us to be better than them
inshallah so we should demonstrate that
I don't know bro we're having a moment
is it something you'd like to say
all right so two comments that I want to
address number one sneako admitted on
value team and money the I think that's
the podcast with Patrick David the
entrepreneur that he is leaning towards
Islam as a truth and insha Allah he will
submit some and like a mountain Summit
fold and join the brotherhoods here's
the thing bro
it doesn't matter at the end of the day
if he does he does if he doesn't he
doesn't like why are we simping for
non-muslims to give Islam validation we
don't need this even even in Islam like
we know from the Quran like there's no
compulsion in in religion Allah has made
it so self-evident the proofs and
evidence and Clarity Islam being the
truth like we don't need to do anything
over the top and let alone look for
these little crumbs and these these
little things you know why Muslims have
this uh attitude
Hunter used to be Republican and then
change this channel he's so weird here's
the thing for any of you that don't know
this about Hunter Avalon I think that's
what his name is pronounced he used to
be super like far left bro oh sorry he
used to be super far right Republican
conservative
gun control uh sorry gun ownership you
know white supremacy that type of guy he
was super into that bro and then
overnight he completely went to the
Other Extreme of the political Spectrum
bro so he's super pro alphabet gang
super pro abortion super pro feminism
liberalism this happened almost
shockingly bro so you can imagine people
like Matt Walsh which are very far right
Candace Owens very far right they have a
falling based on people that agree with
their ideology you know what I mean so
for him it was very weird because his
whole subscriber fan base was just
conflicted like why are you going from
one side to another you know what I mean
but unfortunately this is where he
stands now he's super liberal and uh
[Music]
can you clarify what you said to Rami
about salafis when he mentioned this is
more important no case
oh no the lag is starting
technical difficulties technical
difficulties can you guys hear me now
yeah thank you okay so let's put this
comment back up five can you clarify
what you said tarami about salafis when
he mentioned this is more important okay
so the term salafi linguistically means
um
I believe those who follow the sale if
that's what salafi is correct correct
now the popular term the the popular
modern day term when people use salafi
is to refer to the Mob those that let's
say you're playing chess and then they
reply to your story being like yo chess
is Haram what are you doing or you know
what I mean those are a little bit over
the top so I said that because y'all
don't have to comfort on these throats
this is not referring to those that are
actually salafi the fact that I even
have to explain this just goes to show
how seriously people are taking these
things
um and it's not meant to disrespect the
Salah for anything like that I'm talking
about those that are just a little bit
extreme the prophet saws mentioned you
know do not be extreme in matters of
Faith you know Islam is a middle Nation
so I don't know why that's so hard for
you guys to understand yeah and just one
more side note if you are a person who
actually practices you know salafia and
so on and so forth okay nor is inshallah
but just know there are people who also
claim to practice salafia that would
criticize you like you've never seen
before you know certain followers of
certain are so
Stern on their not just their mother but
their strain of their meth Hub that if
you differ with them in a slight
slightest they will come for your throat
um in a very harsh manner as well so
right going to many opinions there is an
opinion even most opinion that chess is
Haram if it takes you away from the
remembrance of Allah but what wouldn't
be then Haram anything could be if it
takes you away from Allah does that make
sense so understand the way you are
getting your knowledge from
um there is many scholars as well that
say playing soccer is Haram because you
are you are following rules other than
the ruling the Hokum of Allah like okay
so now I'm not gonna go speeding in a
traffic zone am I going to run red
lights now because I don't want to
follow the laws of traffic like that
where do you draw the line you know uh
so I think we need to use our uncle
sometimes let me let me put this video
online
I spoke to his father about the uh the
whole southern thing
and he said that it's for the most part
it's
it's people that are outside of like the
Middle East that when they consider
themselves salafi they're just too
extreme with it but like the actual
people who sell the feet who like that's
that's the proper
um I guess you could say sector the way
of uh you know I've seen this like
during Islam taken from Islam and all
that it's like they're pretty I don't
know it's pretty normal it's it's not
extreme how you see with uh the people
in the west people in Europe and stuff
like this I mean I kind of witnessed it
myself
when I was in when I was in Egypt
alhamdulillah
may Allah bless you for
your journey bro in Islam it's been
overwhelming and an emotional
rollercoaster say the least to say the
least and I think that's been the case
with most you know reverts but uh Miller
bless you bro because you still show up
every single day alhamdulillah so we are
gonna uphold the problems that we made
600 700 uh viewers inshallah we will
start the reaction uh smash that like
button guys come on let's let's get uh
okay listen even even comments like this
let's not slip into backbone bro we you
know back button is is worse than I
think there's uh there's Innovation you
guys can correct wrong but one one act
of backbiting is equivalent to 10 acts
of Xena
so I well I've never heard that before
so so if that is true under and it is a
major sin for back but in regardless of
what you say is a major sin so
understand that whatever the case may be
if we agree with sergeant if we don't
agree with sergeant if we agree with
anyone we're not going to do back button
here and we I don't want you guys
spreading this fit now because not only
are you going to get the sins for no
reason anyone that submits to the will
of your emotional unintelligence in the
live chat is also going to get sins now
for no reason so let's be smarter than
that
all right now
kids are just obeys you in some ways the
Quran does order Muslim men to like
strike their wives do you think that's
okay I mean if it works for them I
wouldn't do that I think I can uh show
discipline and show what is it okay wait
these are such easy questions like is it
good to beat wives uh no but like sneako
you know the red pill brain just kicks
in hey do you think it's okay to beat
the [__] out of your wife like what it
says in in the Quran
um you know if it works for them wait if
it works for who do you think it's like
it's working for the wife while she's
getting her head bashed in you think
she's like well at least this is working
for our marriage I don't think so
[Music]
now we all know and love sneak out we've
talked about him quite a lot on this
channel and uh he's like the the present
that keeps on giving you know one second
you think finally it's over he's gone
officially too far he's crossed that
line there's no way he's coming back
from this one and then somehow like a
evil doppelganger of Jesus Christ when
you think he's gone he's not and poof he
rises from the dead once again to drop
an even worse take it's like how many
bad takes can one human being formulate
inside of their brain we will never know
until we get some kind of data
collection done on sneako himself so
sneako recently had a conversation with
our friend Destiny where he was asked
some questions about Islam now most
people who watch me know that I'm
incredibly big
Islam based in red pill when it comes to
Islam uh basically I am of the flaming
hot opinion that Islam like most other
religions is garbage and of course Islam
like a lot of other religions also
supports oppressive disgusting beliefs
and Views when we're talking about women
gay people progress Etc sneaker okay
listen look at this this little 10
minute video is probably gonna take us
two hours because of all that we have to
say but to keep us in sync for
background context right because it's
important context is everything
including in Islam
um this man was far right as I mentioned
he was super Christian right super about
that life he was uh about these
Traditional Values religion and all that
he then left Christianity so it's
important to note that and I believe
he's also an atheist now so just so you
guys know where he's coming from Combine
that with being a lib he is going to
Super uh go anti to theism
I want to comment more on that in the
future inshallah just just remind me
because it's an important Point sure
let's not insult people again like
listen if you don't like what he's
saying you know I don't like it any more
than you but let's let's deal with it in
a way that will actually benefit people
I don't think you saying that is making
much of a difference
so I'm gonna put up the Super Chat and
then we can begin bro okay inshallah
come on yeah
I have no idea how much uh
oh it's gonna bless you for the support
inshallah
U accept their ideas
I mean
no was recently asked what does he think
about Islam let's find out what sneako
has to say surely there's not going to
be anything here discussing or shocking
in any any conceivable way in fact I'm
sure this is going to be akin to a
religious sermon that enlightens all of
us take it away sneako do you think
Islam is the most like red-filled
religion in case you still didn't hear
that she said do you think Islam is the
most red pilled religion now remember uh
in this little discussing hell world
that's Nico inhabits red pill is just
short for hating women being against
progress and overall having bot talking
points associated with Alex Jones that's
pretty much what prime pill means that's
a good question
um Dave the first uh person who red pill
me I think early on was Malcolm X and
like his his life what's funny about
that doesn't he but
I'm sorry oh did you know that Malcolm X
is the leftist
yeah but he also was pro-segregation he
had a lot of uh right-wing ideas too
what
what okay yeah but he was also his Pro
segregation okay I like how he doesn't
even try to hide it he's like yeah Pro
segregation you know right wing right
um I think he was anti-immigration
um
yeah and I like the fact that he
converted to Islamic jail same thing
with Dave Chappelle you converted to
Islam
a lot of people that I that I respect
ended up finding Islam so I think that
there's something to that is Andrew Tate
um yeah
uh okay so as we know Andrew Tate
converted to Islam not too long ago so
we all know that sneako rides Andrew
Tate's dick harder than a hundred dollar
gay prostitute ever would odds are snico
is feeling a desperate need to defend
Islam because his big daddy Andrew Tate
is a Muslim now
um who I'm closer with he's uh he's a
Christian entertain getting banned off
of Twitter is like his version of going
to jail and like converting to Islam
all social media Airbnb every single not
just Twitter
uh Define grooming
um trying to
quickly trying to raise children into
doing sexual acts or you know becoming
sexual with an adult in the future yeah
it's gross okay I'm really glad that she
clarified that for snico I feel like he
might have thought grooming is when you
uh take a shower and then comb your hair
and use a hair dryer and put on
deodorant yeah okay
jokes I want to make it clear I don't
think anyone thought that's what he
meant by grooming but how do you feel
about like the fact that Muhammad like
married a nine-year-old girl or am I
just strong about that
um listen I was just Hustle
I don't know how true that is I'm not
gonna I'm gonna speak that's like
territory you're about to get a lot of
people excited about it but I don't
think any Muslims are not it
I think it's common knowledge no that's
true then he's not been you know
nobody's perfect
I mean a lot has been said already
there's bro we can talk for like 20
minutes 30 minutes just about these
these few sentences listen we'll we'll
do a quick little pause before we go
into the video guys smash that like
button we're about to go on this one
what do you think so far bro no one's
perfect if that is the case no one's
perfect
okay the first the stuff about
um anti-progress anti this anti-dat
um that was a clip it's going I believe
it's gonna come up later in the video so
I'm Gonna Save All That for when he
mentions in the actual video
um I don't want to go base off that clip
but based on uh what sneakers asked
about the Prophet Muhammad
I actually I don't think scenico's
aiming to disrespect this now I think
sneakers actually
um for lack a better word scared to
disrespect Islam again because he knows
basically what some Muslims are based
you know what well some of them are
gonna do not that Islam really
encourages that kind of behavior but
unfortunately some people don't fully
abide by Islamic rules and he doesn't
want that heat he doesn't want that hate
so I think he's actually trying to be
fair I don't think he has anything to do
with Andrew Tate and he has a person I
think actually respects Islam a lot now
the the prophet peace be upon Him
marrying
not only were there a lot of details
left out of that point but anyone you
ask that question to nowadays is going
to view it in the lens of nowadays this
is called the fallacy of presentism
historians must use this when looking at
previous societies
um I'm not going to get into the I
really want to talk about the New
Testament stuff I'm not going to get
into that because that's a great example
of how when we view what they say back
then we understand it one way but maybe
it was a figure of speech for them they
understand it a different way now what
does it have to do with Aisha
at the time and all throughout history
actually the point where a a child
becomes an adult is when they hit
puberty
when they hit puberty they're basically
viewed as an adult men were going to
Wars and fighting battles uh because
they were considered adults men would
young men would have their own families
and that stuff sometime after you know
soon after hitting puberty because they
were considered men and women as well
this is not something that was strange
that was weird and the prophet Muhammad
peace upon Him is not like the weirdo
outside the box none of his absolute
haters even criticized him for that
because this was something that was
normal now Islam actually came to
regulate a lot of of the things on
marriage like for example polygeny
before there was no limit it's not
limited it to four without completely
removing it because we believe there's
nothing wrong with it as long as it's
done controlled
um secondly Islam says that they must be
physically mentally emotionally mature
now the prophet did the marriage
contract through the permission of
um you know Abu Bakr her father
when she was six and then waited three
years to actually be with her until she
hit puberty and she was mature in that
sense now this nowadays is illegal and
we wouldn't do it no muslim in the world
would well I don't say in the world but
you know in most parts of the world
wouldn't do it today because um children
don't mature like they did back then not
just physically because they were in a
hotter climate which speeds up the
process of puberty but because
um a lot of kids you know they're not
put into the real world they're sitting
on iPads and and so on and so forth so
um it's a completely different world and
this is the thing that people I want you
to understand this is the simplest way
for me to explain it if you live back
then you would be doing the same thing
and you would have no problem with it
right a lot actually one more point I
don't know where Hunter lives but I love
making this point because California I
don't know what their political leaning
is but they seem to be very very
left-leaning very left-leaning in
California any one of any age can get
married with parental consent so if the
prophet peace be upon Him existed today
and I shared existed today and they did
exactly what they did today there would
be no problem with it if they got you
know legally married with the permission
of the father in California there would
be no legal repercussions it's
completely allowed let me you know let
me add something to that so basically
what you're saying is throughout history
everyone deems that an adult means that
they're of mature age they've incited or
initiated puberty right but Islam was
the first thing that came and basically
said that it is not until this age of
maturity that you can consummate a
marriage
so not only that I want to add to the
fact that I know what you were saying is
is fine that she had the consent but
before the prophet saw him basically
wanted to marry she was already engaged
to someone else
and and it's very this is something that
is extremely important to predicate this
upon because it just goes to show the
normalcy of that however there are
people saying that you know P was
accepted back then or Aisha was six
years old when the prophet saw some
married her and was nine year old and he
consummated the marriage and this was
something uh and another comment said
that the this thing
you cannot reduce the prophet saw some
because of this being normalized no this
was never being normalized going for
someone before the age of consent or
puberty and consummating the marriage
this was never okay this was something
that you find the Bible this is
something you find in Western history
and European history but this was never
something that was part of Islam
Additionally the life expectancy back
then was about 31 to 33 years women as
soon as they enter puberty they all
started having kids this is something
like across the board just do a little
bit of research and think about it
inshallah will be fine
um
Aziz writes how was I unsubscribed from
this channel
bro you guys already know YouTube's
coming after us
yeah but I hope that clears it up
because again like when you view any
point of History through your lens with
your court cultural norms and moral
beliefs and you know outlook on the
world
you're going to see a lot of history
um is weird or different or strange or
bad or wrong
um even like imagine like all the
Spartans why were the Spartans so keen
on being Warriors and Fighters and you
know oh that must have sucked why why I
believe they loved it because that is
what men that that was what a man was
back then so it wasn't an issue for them
nowadays people just want to make money
and and you know engage in their own
uh hidden a stick uh Pleasures but
that's because that's what liberalism
teaches you so again policy of
presentism I want to address top Striker
Academy writing p is not acceptable I'm
gonna be honest with you I agree Islamic
Greece no one's denying this bro what I
want you guys to understand is there is
a very amazing refutation on this topic
because this is a bothersome topic you
know we as Muslims we're never going to
be on the uh wave where it's like okay
God knows best accept it have Blind
Faith we don't want any of this so I
want you to understand that this
YouTuber his name is full metal theist
by the way he came out with a very
extensive I think 30 or 40 minute plus
refutation on this very going in depth
into this and it's very palatable for
even a Layman it's not anything too
technical or anything I highly recommend
you guys to watch it inshallah so uh the
videos by YouTuber a brother named full
metal theist and I think the video is
titled the end of the P argument
something like that inshallah so if
you're serious about it and you want to
actually challenge your views and get
some education watch it if you want to
continue being arrogant
you you have free will bro I'm not going
to tell you what to do
I know anything else you want to add
okay then with another it's their ideas
okay so here we're greeted by the first
amazingly insightful take here from
sneak out what do you think about
grooming how do you feel about Prophet
Muhammad marrying a nine-year-old in
reality by the way Prophet Muhammad
married the girl when she was six and
then [__] her when she was nine just
to be clear you know that way we make
sure we get those lovely details
accurate and upon hearing this sneako
responds nobody's perfect I'm sorry what
nobody's perfect that's the that's the
excuse you use when you forget to take
the trash out okay that's the excuse you
make when when you accidentally overcook
your toast one day not oh I rape the
child well nobody's perfect you know hey
everybody makes mistakes around here
we're all human okay I don't know what
was that that's the deposit for a second
why is this guy so emotional
um I think that just his temperament bro
in general I don't think that he seems
very triggered in a lot of the videos
I've seen yeah I can I can see why you
know people of his um his political
standing or whatever uh watch his video
he's entertaining but unfortunately in
this case I've heard him have you know
interesting takes and interesting points
and I think he's a very articulate
person but in this case he's not saying
anything really like what does he just
what is he saying he's just asserting a
lot of uh non-truths about the prophet
peace be upon him and uh painting it as
something that especially for the time
again was completely normal and there's
no issue with it and there was no harm
to either
and if there was they wouldn't have
engaged in you know you know marrying at
that age or anything again that is why
they waited but he's not really saying
anything he's just kind of going on this
emotional tangent and insulting and
he's really like if you think about it
what point is he making he's just
yelling out sneako criticizing him and
talking about how bad sneaker was and
trying to throw a stem under the bus I
think he because of Christianity has
done a I'm Gonna Save it because it ties
into the big point about liberalism in
the history of that so I'm gonna hold my
tongue for when it comes up
they've all committed pedophilic acts of
rape before was just part of The Human
Experience you know nobody's perfect
okay I forgot to take the trash out you
raped five kids you know we're all kind
of the same this is hysterical in one of
the most disturbing ways comprehensible
to mankind what the [__] is wrong with
you creep now I'm gonna pull this up as
well so I went over this okay and uh
because because people dispute sometimes
the nine-year-old wife thing so the
wife's name the nine-year-old girl was
Aisha so
these are are multiple different
passages I believe from the Quran or the
Hadith all reporting on Aisha's age he
stayed there for two years or so and
then married Asia when she was a girl of
six years old and he consummated that
marriage when she was nine years old
this is generally considered the second
most reliable collection of the hadiths
she writes that Muhammad Allah's
messenger married me when I was six
years old and I was admitted to his
house at the age of nine here when she
was seven years old she was taking the
house as a bride when she was nine and
her dolls were with her and when he the
holy prophet died she was 18 years old
this is another part from the Hadith
written by Aisha herself the Apostle of
Allah may peace be upon Him married me
when I was seven years old the narrator
Suleiman said or six years he had
intercourse with me when I was nine
years old so yeah but anyway that's uh
that's snico saying nobody's perfect you
know nobody's perfect that's why
Muhammad had to rape a child
okay you know okay Nobody's Perfect all
right I'm sorry again this this notion
of like okay
um I don't I don't know about that I
haven't read those passages
um but regardless like what what
definition are we using because it's a
lot of assertions but you're not
actually defining uh What You Mean So
when you say that word I'm not going to
say you know because we might get uh you
know taken away bro grape like the fruit
okay type so with that word what are you
actually saying that is when you do the
Act without consent it's it's force or
coercion or you get them in a state
where they don't know even what they're
doing you know if they intoxicate them
to that point and then you take
advantage of them
again especially especially for the
context that's not what it was and there
was cases of of that in in the time the
prophecy peace be upon him and when the
person was found he was actually
um put to offing not living anymore
right
um and that's an Islamic law so there's
no such allowance for this in Islam
and it doesn't fit even what you're
saying you know because
she accepted because it's an obligation
for the woman to also want to do it and
if she didn't want to it would have been
eradicated like in her first marriage
and then
um waited three years for her to even be
able to basically and by their standards
get to the age where she is allowed to
you know consent or whatever
and by the way all of Nika the whole
point of the contract is that I consent
I'm going to be with this person and be
uh you know sexual with this person
that's literally the whole point it's
unlawful to be sexual any basically with
anyone else unless you have that that
marriage contract with them so you're
just making these assertions without
actually I think even understanding the
context or you know what you're saying
and how it relates to the context
hmm
all that because he said one word bro
what do you mean restricted prohibited
no prohibited yeah
um
yeah yeah but I mean I would I would
like his take on that you know I as far
as I know I've at least heard maybe it's
speculative but statistically most
people who you know
um whatever with children
are from that group or that inclination
so I'd like his take on that mm-hmm all
right let's get let's get back to the
video
even with another it's the hadiths to
the Quran if your wife cheats or
disobeys you in some ways the Quran does
order Muslim men to like strike their
wives do you think that's okay I mean if
it works for them I wouldn't do that I
think I can uh show discipline and show
what
is it okay wait these are such easy
questions like is it good to rape
children uh no is it good to beat wives
uh no but like sneako you know the red
pill brain just kicks in hey do you
think it's okay to beat the [__] out of
your wife like what it says in in the
Quran
um you know if it works for them what if
it works for who do you think it's like
it's working for the wife while she's
getting her head bashed in because she
wouldn't suck her husband's dick long
enough
again like I wanna I wanna be clear on
this in
the fourth chapter of the Quran in the
34th Ayah or verse right it very clearly
says that there is a an order or
sequence or hierarchy of how we should
maintain
responsibility and Authority
and you know you abandon her bed stop
talking to her all these yada yada yada
and then at the very end
what does it say about me just so we're
clear on it because we're not sugar
coating the dean what does it say
um
after sorry I wasn't listening to the
Ayah after it said what is the what is
the phrase that they take out of context
oh yeah yeah um
uh it says
which means actually not B but strike
okay now the tafsir from you know and
you can correct me from wrong bro it's
to literally use something like a Miss
walk something literally harmless not
even to hit her not to inflict damage
pain or none of that right
and just to demonstrate your physical
power over her to basically show that
this is what it's come to I don't want
it to go to this I would rather divorce
you than do this there's never been the
process of some there's no evidence no
Hadith nothing he never hit women never
beat women nothing like that never went
against anyone's will nothing so I don't
know why it's so hard for them to
understand this bro yeah and I mean even
the way he's describing it it shows a
clear lack of understanding
um of Islam in general
when he described oh you know when a
wife is is getting her head bashed in
um for not you know whatever whatever
for the husband this is not what Islam's
talking about stuff
um the prophet peace be upon him
actually I'm going to use narration the
Hadith just like you mentioned
um and there's a narration from Aisha
where she said the prophet peace be upon
him never hit his wives or even an
animal he never hit at all his wives are
even an animal
right and there are cases there are
cases of that you know in in at the time
and Islam makes it unequivocally clear
that you are not allowed to harm your
wife in any way
in any way shape or form it's completely
Haram and our example is a prophet peace
be upon him he uh he never did that now
there's a Hadith from one of the
companions of the Prophet I don't know
if it's
but one of them actually said yeah with
a miswak or something it's a small stick
you know how do you beat someone with a
small uh like a toothpick you know a
small Branch
um or some not Branch branch is a little
big but a small stick you can't do that
and the whole point of it actually is to
limit any kind of domestic abuse to not
allow it to disallow it to prohibit it
and to basically like you say I it's
actually a symbol of divorce
so we have this thing called talak and
with talaq you're supposed to basically
like like hit her lightly on the arm
here it's literally a symbol that I'm
I'm literally about to divorce you I've
gone to a point where I I don't want to
be with you anymore and I think even
more evidence of this is if you think
critically divorce is allowed in Islam
but in this situation where the woman is
not listening to her husband she's she's
completely disobeying him she's going
off the rails of whatever situation you
want to paint and he advised her advised
her advisor she won't listen so he's not
even sleeping beside her she still won't
listen what comes after that divorce
it's divorce isn't mentioned in the Ayah
which which shows that this last step
daughter which some say actually means
the kind of part ways or to leave
actually means divorce and before you
divorce you actually tell her listen I'm
getting to this point that's actually
what it signals that's why even Allah
and other Scholars they say when you do
it you cannot cause pain you can't even
leave a mark
you can't cause bloodshare or anything
how do you beat someone or strike
someone without even causing pain and
one last evidence I want to give just to
make it unequivocally clear there's a
narration of a job you know Ayub or job
as some people say in the Quran and he
was at a very you know low point in his
life Allah was testing him he was sick
he couldn't even move maybe he thought
he was going to die in that state and he
said to his wife who kept asking him to
pray to God to make things better he was
too shy to ask Allah because he was
blessed his whole life
he was like wallahi I think he said but
he made an oath when I get better I'm
gonna beat you I'm gonna lost you 70
times or something like that maybe you
thought I was gonna die in this but
that's how angry he was and then he got
better and he was like oh
I kind of made an oath so what do I do
Allah told him to take grass grass and
to lash his wife with with grass
it's like essentially just tickling her
just
and this these are our prophets he swore
an oath by God that he should not break
especially as a prophet and Allah the
way he gave out he didn't say oh just
hit her no he said take something that's
not going to hurt her at all and do it
because you're still technically
fulfilling your oath
Islam is
understanding you have is completely
flawed it's westernized and uh unislamic
you guys know a YouTuber named over
Donia
yeah I think I think he's on Tick Tock
he's watching us now I love his shorts
bro they're so like to the point and he
always he has a little bit of uh sarcasm
in his in his I love it bro and it's
straight up sometimes satirical but it
goes right to the point and it's always
evidence-based and uh mail addressing
for that bro you're always welcome
bro I just messaged him saying that his
stuff is so underrated sneako needs a
detox alive with you guys and share with
one with the great oh we've already done
that we've done a lot with with him
uh young Don another YouTuber knows
something guys that was like that was
like a whole villain Arc bro we don't
know we're not even getting into that so
yeah
um one more note on snico just quickly I
don't think I don't know why Muslims are
mad at him like he's the one insulting
Islam
I think it's because he does not want to
insult Islam that he's he's trying to
put it off you know the way it's wrong
you know because these things are
detestable things but they're just not
an Islamic problem he just doesn't know
that because the way it's being put to
him is that it isn't a semi problem he's
going based off the words of these
people who don't know any any more than
him
um and are misconstring the situation
either intentionally or unintentionally
so I don't think we should be jumping on
him saying you know oh look at him he's
not he's not the one salted insulted
saying he's the this he's that there's
actually there's another guy who's
saying that and I think we should focus
on this one thing do you really do you
remember bro the we did this reaction to
Destiny Abba and sneako and Destiny has
a history of trying to put snico in this
weird box that you're not allowed to
disrespect any religion until you
disrespect Islam knowing that he doesn't
want to do it so I'm not really
surprised bro yeah
but why Nico is still associating with
them that's beyond me bro
I think she's like well at least this is
working for our marriage
I think so when you say it works for
them you mean it works for the abusive
disgusting sub-human husband who's
beating the [__] out of his wife maybe
it works for him I'm pretty sure the
woman getting beaten probably isn't
working out so good for her it works for
them again this is what you say when
you're asked questions about like an
open marriage well you know if it works
for their relationship that's fine not
is it okay to beat your partner but once
again Hunter Avalon here with the
incredibly hot takes like uh don't be
don't don't beat your wife kids don't do
it it's bad it works for them I wouldn't
do that I think I can um show discipline
and show in different ways when you say
like if it works for them you're like
indifferent if some men beat their wives
I mean it worked for a long time like
before the 70s like it worked for a long
time no it didn't you chuckle [__] are
you okay right now did you did you pop
one too many red pills this morning
buddy did you overdose on your
prescription what the [__] are you
talking about it did not work for a long
time what happened for a long time is
wives were beaten treated like
second-class citizens abused and raped
viciously and constantly by their
husbands and a lot of the times nothing
would happen because of it he brings up
the 70s and we will play the rest of his
clip here in a minute but back before
the 70s uh I believe that domestic abuse
was handled as a domestic issue police
wouldn't even get involved if the wife
had been beaten by her husband a lot of
the times they would just let the family
handle that and this allowed for that
abuse to continue I know bro why are you
smiling still
because I saw a comment that said never
trust a person with low testosterone
yeah but what is what is a chuckle F
like what is it I've never I'm 25 bro
I've never heard that in my existence no
consequences this didn't work for a long
time sneak out for a long time wives
were abused and treated like
second-class citizens this isn't working
for a long time okay this is the problem
by the way when you uh neglect studies
and would rather go by personal
experience like snico and these other
red pill chuckle [__] like to do
instead of hey was domestic abuse
occurring back then or not well you
didn't hear about it right so it was
probably not as big of a deal that's his
mindset here because you didn't hear
about it because you didn't see it
happening then it probably wasn't a big
deal but in reality behind the scenes
wives everywhere were being abused
ah
I don't think there's much of a point to
say on that to be honest um he's just
saying you know women in the past have
been abused and abuse is bad we would
agree with that um I agree with one
thing he said yeah the you should do
some research you shouldn't just jump on
what you think I agree bro and my
message to Hunter is you should do your
research too because those that finally
start having a little bit of wisdom
think they're all sciencey all of a
sudden they become atheist sure
but then at the other other side the
other end of that when you finally get a
lot of wisdom a lot of knowledge you
then come back to theism you come back
to believing in God because it's the
only thing that that we know for a fact
is real
yeah
um yeah on that note I do want to add
um and this is not an insult to Hunter I
think I myself uh you know fall into
this category as well uh this partic
especially goes for for young men like
myself and for like Hunter I'm assuming
he's around my age 22 23.
it's very easy for us to sound smart for
us to sound like we know what we're
talking about for us to sound like we've
studied it for years
most of the time especially young men
like myself we have not
and it's very clear to Hunter or in
Hunter's case but not obvious you know
for what his viewers are seeing that he
does not know what he's talking about
but he's very you know um entertaining
very foul mouth but he's very
entertaining people love listening to
this kind of stuff and this dramatic you
know blah blah blah yeah let's both hate
this common enemy together kind of
scheme
so I see why people watch him but it's
not an academic take he's just literally
throwing a tantrum in front of the
camera
and I don't say that to be insulting
what else is he doing and now he's right
in some cases you know what sneako is
saying that oh it's okay it's not a big
deal rushing obviously it's detestable
it's wrong he should not do that
um in Islam but the thing is Islam
doesn't encourage these things like he's
being portrayed and if Hunter did a
little bit of research on his time he
would have known that or maybe he did
and he just doesn't want to be fair this
time Allah
but um I would say take from the older
and those who are a little more learned
we Muslims sure have a lot of enemies
um yeah but you know it's okay we're two
billion people in the world
why is my what my camera's from
Minecraft
quality the quality of your camera bro
it's the connection rule
I see Romi still has a Blackberry bro
like he asked us what's the BBM and I
was like BBM bro who still uses
BlackBerry
well yo you know Andrew Tay said the
same thing not the old Blackberry thing
but he said that uh usually people that
are like younger than 30 just have no no
real clue about what they're talking
about and like they might have like some
knowledge here and there but like it's
knowledge that's usually acquired from
someone else that's older than them or
it might be from like some life
experience but for the most part like
it's not till your your past at least 30
minutes or something like that that you
actually start having
like more real knowledge more wisdom and
life experience and I mean I can I can
honestly say the truth and I can I can
say that for myself like Romney you said
it for yourself but I'm sure you can say
it for yourself
you know like I bro I have a YouTube
channel where I'm like talking about
these things and I can sit back and say
yeah I don't know
a hundred percent like that's why I
don't make that many videos because I
don't know as much as uh many people
think that I would know
you know what I'm saying I'm just trying
to like just bring it back here with
like
the real question I want to ask
is wise as this guy so emotional and his
response about Islam and stuff like this
yeah what happened with him and his
experience with this slam that he's
acting this emotional about it yeah I
think I think there's a level of emotion
that is Justified because you're talking
like from his perspective he's he's
talking about domestic you know hitting
and um
uh having intercourse with someone
without their consent and all these
things which terms I will not say for
the sake of art how uh how how much of a
w stream would it be if in this stream
of Hunter going off someone comes and
actually takes it shahada bro someone
new
just imagine bro that would be amazing
but slingshot can you can you comment if
if you're actually ready like you've
done a little bit of research
um you know a little bit about Islam and
we can get you on the stream you don't
have to even have your video it can be
Audio Only we'll walk you through it
inshaallah
um we're gonna stream for another maybe
Max 30 minutes inshallah so we'll
comment and if that's the case uh reach
out to me on Instagram and I will send
you the link inshallah type okay now I
want to finish my point yes which is
that I think a level of emotion is
Justified because these are you know
motion inducing topics they are horrible
acts but the problem is that when he
throws it onto Islam and just insults
our Prophet our beloved Prophet peace
and blessings be upon him
um who actually
has been a
um a a beacon of
um I'd say progress
positive progress in the world
because of the religion that he brought
and the effect it had on the people
around him and we will get into that
inshallah
yeah well I mean if you Google it he's
the most influential man
in all of history
very true very true the book from
Michael Hart the 100.
he wanted to put Jesus and Paul above
the process and but he couldn't he
that's what he wrote actually
let's get back to the video can you can
you keep an eye on the comments bro when
uh when slingshot comments we need to
add them up because I can't really see
the live chat too well yeah
okay we don't want to miss it
actually there is one more
hey Anthony people use rhetoric to make
themselves appear articulate button uh
but uh in all honesty it's just a front
that indicates they don't know what
they're talking about a lot of the time
a lot of the time actually that is the
case now maybe some people know what
they're talking about and they're very
you know um rhetorical in their speech
and they're very articulate but a lot of
the time you know they don't know what
they're talking about and a good way to
test this is just think what are they
actually saying
what are they actually saying what are
the implications of this does this fully
line up just think critically about
their statements people shouldn't be
afraid to engage with you know
non-muslims who are saying things about
stem there's no problem just you know
look into it I'm delivered the brothers
done research on Islam bro do you have
Instagram if you have Instagram please
DM at the three Muslims right DM ASAP
and I will send you a link to this
stream
and uh inshallah just uh you can join
anytime bro
Miller accept it from you bro Allah I
mean
so no this did not work for a long time
sneako for a little while it just wasn't
talked about and recognized as a massive
issue the way that it is nowadays
I mean it worked for a long time like
before the 70s like it was common for
the husband to you know give her a slap
once in a while she was acting up but
you know that's going to get you in jail
now so I'm not gonna navigate anybody to
do that I don't think I'll look at this
weasel listen to this weasel [__] right
here you know back in the 70s you could
smack her if she was acting up so what
does it mean for your wife to act up oh
right it's completely subjective and
arbitrary so it's up to the husband to
decide so maybe if he doesn't like the
fact that his wife wants to I don't know
go to art class then he can beat the
[__] out of her because in his mind
that's her acting up right there's no
real way to measure whether or not she
is acting up that's just left up to the
drunken husband's subjective discretion
so first of all that doesn't even make
sense second of all listen to this guy
weasel away from actually owning the
position you talk such a big game about
being the alpha who's not a bot who's
not afraid to say it how it is bruh but
now you're weaseling away from owning
the incredibly despicable position that
you've pretty much already owned now
when push comes to shove well it's
illegal so I'm not really advocating for
it shut the [__] up you spineless [__]
go now so I'm not gonna Advocate anybody
to do that I don't think also yeah I
don't think hitting women is good you
should be able to control you know
control the situation in different ways
okay so he he so it worked for a long
time if it works for some couples it's
cool you're also not saying to do it
because you know it's illegal and then
at the very end we get the little cherry
on top but it is bad to hit women okay
I'm just gonna just gonna pause it real
quick so uh slingshot mentioned he
doesn't have Instagram so in that case
slingshot just enter your email into
this chat do not enter the whole email
because YouTube is gonna block that from
being a comment so just enter everything
before you write the ad and then the
Gmail or Yahoo or whatever the heck that
is just enter what the term is if that
makes sense just the main thing before
the AD Sign and start correctly
um with any underscores or anything like
that and once that is done then send the
second uh
comment saying if it's Gmail or
something like that
because we're doing this no matter what
inshallah today
thank you wow you finally managed to
come around to the right position dude
Destiny are you Pro or against beating
women
what are you looking at what you've been
looking at this whole time I think
that's the end of it already that is a a
surprisingly terrible take even for
somebody such as sneako domestic abuse
worked for a long time raping children
nobody's perfect my God this guy gets up
here by the way on Twitter and he feigns
moral outrage about things like vaccines
and mandates he acts like he's so moral
and courageous for being against the
vaccines and the mandates and Bill Gates
and all the typical conspiracy bot
talking points he thinks he's so brave
and so so moral so virtuous when it
comes to this but then when it comes to
the issue of domestic abuse or child
rape you can't even take a hard position
it takes you a [__] half hour to
weasel your way through a bunch of
mental gymnastics to finally land on the
well you know beating women it is bad by
the way did I mention don't do that what
a [__] sneak out is a pathetic piece of
[__] the fact he has any relevance at
all still is concerning I think that it
speaks volumes to how uh deranged and
degenerated our society has become
somehow he garnered an audience mostly
from sucking Tate's dick and now this is
where okay is there any benefit to the
restaurant you know because I think he's
just like
just going on an emotional Outburst
against Nico
um and I think there's a way to
articulate this without
um the vulgar language did you see any
comments bro and no
um I have not yet and most people when
he comments they they put oh he
commented he commented we just got to
find it but um
I don't know I haven't seen it yet
but
um he didn't I thought the clip from the
beginning would come back but I didn't
see it come back so
um while we're waiting for the comment
and now maybe if I if you're able to see
the comments then you can you know keep
an eye out while I kind of trying to bro
trying to uh slingshot please answer
your email
so
this whole thing about uh religion
um being anti-progress and look at how
he just puts all religions or at least
the three abrahamic religions under the
same boat as being anti-progress not
anti you know
um word I can't say but it's a certain
Community it starts with an L has a b
and a t in it as well community
um slingshot what we're saying is enter
everything in your email before that
sign you know
so if yeah
let me let me give you an example let's
say rami's email is going to be Rami 69
gmail.com let's just say this is his
email
so what you need to comment is rami69 if
you comment Romi 69 gmail.com YouTube is
going to bend because anytime you enter
a phone number email personal sensitive
uh information it will block that out so
you need to answer it as it is without
the at gmail.com so for example Rami
would enter rami69 once again that is r
a m i six nine
did you just give away Romney's email
perhaps
but just a little bit bro because it's
only one of his six emails
type okay so to get back to the main
point he puts religion into one category
that they're all anti this anti-lot and
then he says anti-progress what the heck
does that even mean anti-progress that
since we're not willing to change our
practices or beliefs we cannot progress
I'm pretty sure there's what do you
believe that any moral belief you have
now should it change
if you did believe that then you
probably would not have those beliefs
so why are you acting
as if beings you know having a strong
position and not changing your moral
beliefs or your position is something
that is bad or you know I don't want to
benefit Society I don't want to benefit
myself so I'm going to stay stagnant in
this way the reason is because when you
look throughout European history you'll
find that the church
and the the kings that were given the
Divine Divine Right To Rule The the
Divine kingship from God held the people
from progressing for a long time a lot
of Europe like maybe only 25 percent of
Europe was you know civilized and the
roads were paved and the people were
living decently everyone else was
suffering
insanely and there was no progress and
it was only through fighting the Muslims
that they were able to see how the
Muslims lived and how it was
tremendously better significantly better
because of Islam and what Islam has
caused them to develop and I will speak
about that inshallah in a bit so after
the Europeans fought against the Muslims
and they saw the benefit of living in
Islamic Society or like the Muslims
later on they translated a lot of Arabic
books from Elk and everything from
legislation law and politics to medicine
to math to science to religion to
philosophy everything literally
everything you can imagine they
translated it into Latin
and they used it as the groundwork for
their own progress they created secular
liberalism
they had this notion the same notion
that you have hunter that all religion
is bad all religion is anti-progress and
all religion is going to keep us under
so then they created liberalism John
Locke and others created liberalism
which is let's maximize the freedom of
the individual if they want to believe
whatever that's in their heart that's in
their house but outside in the real
world people can basically do whatever
they want as long as they're not harming
anyone else even if they harm themselves
Islam does not allow such a thing Islam
values the good of the community over
the good of the individual and there's a
lot more that I won't get into but when
you look at Islam
the belief in God was actually the
starting point for people
uh to develop the scientific method
people like IBN Cena IBN and haitham
they actually developed the scientific
method because of God because I told
them what the universe exists in a
concrete way where God has given it
certain laws a certain Sunnah way of
being that it's just it's the way where
it's not going to change right it's the
method in which certain things will come
to be and exist and so on and so forth
certain laws and rules and this is
something that actually couldn't be
understood
something that can actually be
understood and used to their advantage
so that's why IBN and heightam started
with Optics and um you know some Muslims
invented algorithms and early
mathematics and and all this stuff
what do you think what do you think
about this he was he was actually he
lived in Muslim society and he believed
he was a Muslim he was influenced by the
same things I'm talking about but
certain beliefs took him out of the fall
of Islam certainly like philosophical
beliefs theological beliefs about it and
and this isn't you making takfir this is
this is on scholarly Consultants
one of the big Scholars they detected on
him
um and he was not he was not able to
respond you know adequately to what the
contentions that he was given but
regardless
um the point is that under Islamic rule
under Islamic governance under Islamic
Society under the Quran the same Quran
the Muslims and and even IBN scene in
this case was reading they developed
methods because of this right
so and that's trolling man's like I'm
not I'm trying my best slingshot buddy
it shouldn't be this hard man all due
respect it's just enter your if it's not
bro I'll just enter my email the problem
is I don't want everyone to spam you
know into the three Muslims you know
do you have a better idea or solution
if you really want you can make a
temporary you can go on the temporary
email thing right uh there's websites
that have temporary emails keep the tab
open put the tablet I don't know how to
do that can you do that just oh just go
on a new tab and type temporarily a
temporary email and get whatever the
email is put it in the chat tell me to
email that it will come up inshallah
once he emails it but back to the main
point
back to the main point
under Islamic law and governance these
things thrived from Muslims or people
who are influenced by Islam because of
Islam because they understood that God
created the world in a way that is
constant uh concrete and there are laws
that will not change now and without
this belief you don't have science
because if everything was changing the
the the speed in which light travels in
a vacuum uh would change you know if
that would change then we don't have
anything solid to do use basically do
science based off of now it's not just
Science and Mathematics it's also
legislation innocent until proven guilty
there are even like the I forgot his
name but there's a French historian and
others who actually concluded that
innocent until proven guilty was taken
from the Muslims
was taken from the Muslims
and we have in the Sunnah of the Prophet
peace be upon him and even in the Quran
to bring proof if you want to make a
claim you bring your proof and your
evidences
you know and on top of that the Maliki
school of thought
um developed the jury system
where you have like 13 jurors or
whatever
um in the court and this is something
that again can be traced back to Islam
that we use nowadays in our law on our
politics innocent so proven guilty the
jury system
so you want to talk about oh
anti-progress these things that
progressed the west and made it so much
better A lot of them actually came from
Islam and even if they weren't directly
from Islam Islam was the groundwork the
basics the stepping stone for these
white Europeans to take all the glory
and say oh we invented this we invented
that and it gets a lot deeper check my
Instagram there's a whole video that
talks about all these amazing things
that uh most likely or or definitely
came from the Islamic world
I think shot said he's going to email
this inshallah still waiting for a
an inbox email bro all you got to do is
just send any email just be like
hi that's fine with me bro
or hey
you can even send the 2i Emoji bro I'm
down whatever you want to do bro slide
into my email
so I can ASAP ASAP just send you the
streamer
uh
can you guys do another stream with
snico he needs Islam
if he's willing to wear down but um
we have not been able to get in contact
with them
well bro everyone needs Islam Islam
doesn't need us no
inshallah
slingshot once you send the email please
just put a comment or something that you
sent the email
still didn't get anything bro
not sad bro
I don't know why why you think I'm sad
man probably the angle that I have the
camera
I don't know that was that was Angel's
happy face
uh can you do a thing with Hunter yeah
bro 100 inshallah we invite him to uh to
discuss it Slammer whatever I'd like to
know his story as well why he went from
right leaning to left leaning because I
think he's just following the the Sunnah
or the path of the the Europeans who
invented secularism and uh liberalism
yeah but if we have them on man's got to
chill out he can't be a person and all
that stuff absolutely absolutely
that's a good point someone's new to the
chat
um uh a brother might take a shahada and
accept this oh I don't know why I
removed that accident um it might take a
shot then accept Islam
uh so we're just waiting to get in
contact with them
um
it's been it's been very consecutive
lately
alhamdulillah
hmm
boys so then in the meantime while we
wait for a slingshot let's do a quick q
a if you guys have any uh any questions
that are relevant today
um no personal questions please ask away
we are here in child love for the people
should love that someone said don't
trust a guy with a testosterone
yeah someone also commented don't trust
a guy with blue hair because Destiny has
blue hair no slingshot one word
literally bro that's all you got to do
even one letter one emoji bro just send
something
I'm saying like in a few minutes then
it's kind of obvious bro like come on yo
y'all remember that movie the driver was
that movie put that comment back up
which one the the one that that you just
had on
this one by the know the fan the fan
page
I I I I don't know the final page or
something like that I lost it
Alano's best we can't see if he's a
troll or not yeah yeah if he comments
your comments in Charlotte let's move on
from it now if he's gonna come he's
gonna comment if not then it's okay but
um and we're not here to question
anyone's intentions listen if he comes
on he's a troll we'll kick him off in a
second no problem we'll move on
um but we should focus on more more
beneficial things he knows he's supposed
to send it so we'll see uh what advice
do you have for finding a decent woman
in the west I think for finding a decent
um you know husband or wife because this
goes for women as well and there's um
certain things that it's it's not so
much about where you look but um what
you look for in a person because you can
find someone you know online like I did
you could find someone at the mall you
can find someone in the Masjid and I
always recommend looking in better
places uh you know like the Masjid as
opposed to places like the mall and
online but regardless for most people I
think when they get married it's kind of
like wow subhanallah this just came out
of nowhere you know it's like I've been
looking for for three years and now I
finally found the perfect person uh it's
all in the hands of Allah but when you
find this person make sure that their
character and their their religion are
are good you know that this person is a
good practicing Muslim in their religion
and that they have good mannerisms with
you and with their family and that stuff
and then
get married bro I think the irony is
that his name is slingshot bro but man's
like slows up
bro that's it that's it right there
that's it look at the picture tell me if
y'all know that movie
oh is that what is that
if y'all know this movie you're a real
one that's all I have to say I'm not
even gonna say the movie name
um
so understand bro in Islam Allah has a
Qatar which is the Divine decree right
that Allah has basically written down
everything that is going to happen from
the beginning of creation till the end
but also understand that Allah does not
make us do these things Allah writes
these things down
these are things that are going to
happen in the future and this is what's
this is what human beings are going to
choose to do every action that Allah has
written down that you and I do in our
lives and that we don't do in our lives
these are because of us we have free
will because if we didn't have free will
none of this would make sense why would
then we be punished for anything we do
because all good and bad is not from us
then but it's because we have free will
Allah just basically writes down what
you're going to do Allah doesn't make
you do it so let's say there's like
three options you're gonna go through
door a door b or door C Allah writes
down you go through door B Allah didn't
make you go through door B you went
through door be yourself but Allah just
basically wrote down this is what you
are going to do because Allah is all
know it does that make sense
I I actually let me message them right
now and ask them to set that up because
I forgot to last time
bro Adrian Adrian's just waiting bro
underrated Sigma
Sigma grinds that
internet is 4 Mbps
I don't know about that bro
slingshot bro come on
everyone's waiting bro
about a thousand people just waiting
here
that's all good man just continue
alhamdulillah
[Music]
what advice would you give a teenage
Muslim uh to give to teenage Muslims who
are trying to learn Dean
um two things one start with the basics
don't jump into the extreme crazy stuff
that's one secondly
um I would say find a teacher you know
if there's a message near you that has
classes or something start there learn
under someone
and read lots of books
um I3 Institute has a yd1 program it's
free it's two hours a week and the
instructors are great the curriculum is
great I've been through and I taught it
before
so that's a good resource
um you know if you don't have anything
near you because it's online
listen no no let's be calm guys listen
let's be some people are just not
technologically savvy come on no let's
have some Grace bro slingshot
I'm not gonna email you anything because
you haven't given me your email what I'm
saying is you need to email me email me
anything bro make the subject anything
make the body anything just make sure to
mention you are slingshot 509 bro are we
cleared do you understand that's all you
got to do you just need to email this
email let me put it again
you just got to email anything bro just
email me anything bro well I will not
take it any other way just just email me
something bro
please y'all remember Shikamaru bro from
Naruto
oh come on bro let me put in bro I never
actually watching on the tour come on
watched a few repeats
see
I'm single writes I'm sorry for being
slow bro it's all good man listen we're
willing to have a little bit of patience
because
what we're doing is for the sake of
Allah right we don't get anything out of
this we want to we would love for you
what we have for ourselves too which is
the sunam so why not have a little bit
of Summer guys in the comments too let's
let's stop with the roasting none of
that
yes it reminds me of this Hadith
were this is one of the sahaba was on
climbing a tree
and his uh his stove was like lifted and
the other sahaba saw how like skinny his
legs were
so they started laughing and then the
prophet Muhammad Ali wasallam told him
that they shouldn't they should stop
they should quit laughing because those
two legs those two skinny legs were
stronger than all their legs combined or
something like this along those lines I
was like we shouldn't roast even if it's
funny like we really shouldn't roast
our own people on brothers and sisters
okay
uh slingshot I'm going to remove this
now
okay take a screenshot of this email
this email that you see that starts with
f is my custom email for now just email
anything bro so I can get your email
let's let's keep it simple
all right
no we shouldn't
because we don't know
we don't know what he's going through
bro have some Subway
um class start during a specific time of
year I'm not sure to be honest online
classes you just join the telegram group
and a zoom meeting once a week and um
that's literally it to be honest you'll
learn you take notes maybe do some
assignments afterwards which are
optional
um but it's it's great alhamdulillah
it's two years fully yd one is one year
yd2 second year but it's all um it's all
only two hours a week in free so just go
to I3 institute.ca and then go to id1
and sign up there
slingshot bro if you don't come you
better change your username bro you can
no longer associate with the name
slingshot this is not gonna happen bro
it also doesn't have to happen live it's
okay we can always open oh I get it bro
but I don't wanna I don't want to lose
communication with them bro he doesn't
have Instagram or anything Miller bless
him he's not on fitna social media up
but come on bro like you got to change
your name to like snail shot or
something after this so
all right I'm going to refresh this
Bismillah
this is a fitness
ah it's not happening bro well we'll
we'll do the live q a if you come you
come if you don't you don't bro all
right guys you can go back to the
the questions
serious questions only no don't be
facetious no come on little
[Music]
um
how much longer y'all trying to do this
let's wrap up oh I should do it for like
another like 10 minutes
invite Luke Belmont next who is that
yeah I haven't heard of him
no more
come on bro I can't email you I don't
know your email you probably commented
your email here but we won't be able to
see it
what slingshot I just joined I don't
even worry bro I'm not even what's going
on nothing else right asks what what's
the Discord for Romney do you want to go
into that
um Discord is for well one I want to
make it a place where you know new
reverse can go so they can you know have
Community around them um or if any
Muslim wants to join for a community
they can do so just a place for people
who support t3m to join and get together
and discuss Islam and um you know
provide a good and insightful Community
for those uh you know around the world
the Muslims hmm
I think inshallah eventually but nothing
is set up right now I'm still waiting
for the reaction video uh that she said
she wants to make I haven't uh I don't
know if they released it yet but I
haven't seen anything
foreign
I'm still learning I've only learned to
control Oneness
one of my naps by the will of Allah
so
the only thing that I can say right now
just keep it very simple and not like go
too crazy crazy in the detail
is
mindfulness
being Mindful and being mindful is a
skill is not something that you can do
in like one moment and then just be
mindless the rest of the day
you know like let's say the entire day
you're on your phone like scrolling
through social media
or you're on YouTube and you're watching
video after video of the video of the
video of the video
if I were to tell you to then be mindful
for like five minutes you wouldn't
actually be able to be mindful you'd
probably be able to be like mindful
maybe like 30 to 40 percent
but if you were the entire day actually
training to be mindful like being as
mindful as you could in every situation
well then the moment that I tell you to
be mindful in those five minutes you'd
probably be at like 70 to 80 maybe even
higher
so it's like the more mindful you can be
then the I'm not gonna say easier it is
but
the better you are more equipped
okay
the nuts when they do come your way
around me is the new Discord link that
you just texted me is that the accurate
one yeah okay alhamdulillah so guys I'm
gonna put the new Discord link here and
feel free to also uh
go to refresh the video check the
description and show that it's gonna be
the new one
for that recommendation well I mean yeah
you guys plan to travel and do meetups
in the future when you grow the channel
more uh inshallah inshallah we're going
to do a meet up in about a week guys but
we won't say the location we're gonna
put out a community post saying meet and
greet and we're probably gonna be there
for like 30 minutes that's it
you gotta let people know a little ahead
of time though you got the email oh let
me check
oh guess what
I still didn't get the email
you have to pay to be on video not on
our platform
how do you avoid interest these days
it's unavoidable this is what was
already mentioned in the Hadith that
it's going to come a time when Rabbi is
going to be unavoidable uh any tips it
seems to be literally everywhere
um
just avoid engaging in contracts that
have interest in it you know whether
it's a credit card or a mortgage or a
loan
um unless there is some kind of absolute
necessity
um no there are ways to have try your
best to avoid this at least
he said would be spread everywhere to
the point where even those who don't
engage in it directly are kind of
afflicted by its dust so there's no way
to fully avoid it in every sense of the
the term but there are ways to not
directly engage in it by taking
contracts you can rent instead of
mortgage you can only spend what you
have in your account instead of a credit
card and getting loans and that stuff
it's difficult sometimes yeah but that's
just what you got to do
hmm
do we follow uh medahab
collectively no not really
um
I usually just go to my chef for
any uh physical rulings that I need
um generally I I prefer the osula of
Imam Allah but that's just me personally
uh well if you weren't knowledgeable of
it and you have a lot of debt just ask
Allah to forgive you and then work to
pay off your debt that's all you can
really do Allah there's a certain amount
of leeway that he gives people
um for being uh you know ignorant on
something so ask a lot to forgive you
don't engage in it anymore and pay off
whatever you owe um
can you guys do a podcast setup tutorial
I want to really start I really want to
start one like you guys inshallah we're
going to be together in about a week
um we can make a quick video inshallah
Romy can you read this out
Fair Muslims no question disappreciation
remain strong and patient and comment
all of you for what you're for all
you're doing Allah I mean
may Allah bless you and make you like
Muhammad
I mean I mean
if someone was addicted to master uh
since a since a young age like
pre-puberty
yeah basically like they they've been
doing it since they were like four years
old or something
but how bro what happens what do you
mean how
I what are they you can you can reach
the the peak without releasing anything
it happens bro oh wow I didn't know that
type anyway bless you bro you're too
pure for this stuff a lot of them but
yeah so um
it's difficult but it's gonna be a full
cold turkey hard detox the answer is not
getting married no the answer is a full
cold turkey hard detox even if you need
to throw your electronics in a box and
lock them away and stay away from it and
be out of your house like 23 hours of
the day then okay so be it you know
that's life uh may Allah make it easy
for you but this is the test that you
have been Afflicted with like many other
you know other people living in today's
world and you have to you know grab it
grab the bull by the horns and deal with
it so I know maybe it sounds harsh but
there's no other answer you just gotta
stop cold turkey and I think Angela has
gone a lot into detail on both his
channel and this Channel about that
yeah I was gonna say man
there's um there's definitely more to
that you know like you definitely hit it
correct he does have to just kind of
like man up and go through it but there
are so many more things that you have to
sit in place
and uh things that you have to take care
of internally that kind of LED you to
begin this whole process of being
addicted to masturbation from such a
young age because it's addictions don't
just happen
it's not like one day it's like oh like
I did this and now I'm addicted no like
an addiction happens because
at some point you were experiencing
something that was just a little bit too
much
and then for you it's like your body
because you couldn't you couldn't cope
with it you couldn't handle the actual
experience you you went for a coping
mechanism you did something to be able
to cope with what was happening and this
is primarily how the addiction starts in
the first place so if you never figure
that out yeah you could man up you get
through it but it's only a matter of
time before all the urges and everything
come right back around full circle and
then the old patterns of behavior take
over and then it's like you're right
back where you started
so there's definitely more but
um these are very good tips like
different you gotta man up and just
start start reflecting start reflecting
more and stay tuned because
we got a little something something
coming I'm not gonna say too much
inshallah but we're gonna be revealing
more on this as time progresses but
we're gonna drop this uh the first Aroma
the Ramadan inshallah inshallah stay
tuned guys be excited for that
can you read this out one month ago I
felt low and with the motivation from
watching you I have returned to my amen
and Salah and ever since I have been
all good is from Allah you know anything
that we do anything that we do that is
good is only by the will of Allah
anything that is wrong or incorrect is
from ourselves our own mistake and from
the shaitaan so may Allah bless you and
increase you and keep you steadfast and
allow you to be an example for those
around you Allah
I love them I mean
we are not Scholars please consult a
scholar for a fatawa
can you talk about how the evolution
theory is wrong and how the story of
Adam as it can scientifically be real so
I mean when you're dealing with science
science only looks for naturalistic
explanations so even if it what is 100
true that God himself created Adam and
Eve and put them on this Earth there's
not going to be any scientific
explanation for that because the
scientific method prohibits any kind of
non-naturalistic explanation so that's
why Evolution uh the evolution the
theory of evolution has to exist now
which uh which Theory you're talking
about which
um form of uh you know Evolution you're
talking about are you talking about like
uh Darwinism neo-darwinism uh
neogenetics what kind of theory are you
referring to there are many theories
um because every single one has a gap in
some way now there are I think deductive
issues and I'm not an expert on this
right I said before it's easy for
someone that sounds smart me as well I'm
not an expert on this you can go to
saburra Ahmadi studied this he's done a
lot of great work and had amazing
discussions about it but when it comes
to for example Darwinism natural
selection there's a huge deductive
problem with it because during the
Cambrian era there were so many
creatures that were just like species
that were just popping up like boom boom
boom boom that it's
insanely
improbable
like insanely improbable
like probably more improbable than
winning the lottery that all these
different species would pop up because
it takes a significant amount of
attempts to produce a certain protein
that could could you know cause a
genetic mutation and so on and so forth
so
many issues with it and even if we take
and we don't have a problem with
Evolution like we can believe that
humans uh go through microevolution and
animals go through micro or maybe even
macro Evolution there's no issue with
that the issue is saying that humans
evolved from an animal or from a common
ancestor with with chimps and apes and
so on and so forth that's that directly
disagrees the Quran and that's why it's
Haram to believe that so there's no real
issue with the theory it's
uh bro I'm laughing because I'm already
getting emails from businessmans being
like yo this is like a Halal investment
opportunity please work with us
this is ridiculous bro
man go on bro slingshot just damn us let
me put the Instagram
so and even Evolution has uh another
issue which uh Stephen Meyer talks about
in his book uh Darwin's doubt
which is the problem of how life
originated on Earth because with
Evolution you have to have one animal
that evolves to another but what
happened with the first living creature
on the face of the earth the earth
didn't always exist so the first living
being didn't always exist so there had
to be a first being now how did this get
here I'm not going to say oh the only
answer is God put him there but this is
an issue with Evolution because you lock
that answer and I don't think there's
any real way of knowing there are
certain
um there are certain theories they have
like clay wet dirt and mud and Clay
provided the perfect atmosphere uh for
the first organism to evolve and it just
evolved and evolved involved over
billions of years uh you know to get to
you know nowadays
but uh there's nothing concrete as far
as I know
actually you know what let me spell it
out from bro
because he's not gonna know what a DM is
yeah
I'm not even trying to make fun of him
direct the message to my Instagram
inshallah
nobody else only slingshot
I don't know bro I got a question for
you
I guess he's uh AFK right now he's he's
gone bro
okay slingshot please take a screenshot
of this I'm gonna take this off the
screen because
we've been at this for almost an hour at
this point
at least 30 40 minutes
what was the question bro
do you really want me to ask you bro
hey bro who are your top three favorite
YouTubers right now that you would want
to bring on the podcast but we haven't
we haven't met them yet
and then I wanted on me to answer that
I mean what do you mean by top
YouTubers all the YouTubers on the
podcast have a stream with them what are
the top three
for example once upon a time I would say
and someone else you know and then we
already got them all so who would you
say no
um
now you only think of two that we
haven't had
and then one that we have had but I
would love to talk to him like more in
depth now and like see what I like
actually I got three I got three in
trouble
um
the first two agitate Tristan Tate
well uh bring them out of jail as
quickly as possible and and may Allah
bro may Allah reveal it to Tristan that
Islam is the only way
amen I would say Andrew the third guest
that I would want
and it and Russ
I didn't think about anyone else the
third person I was gonna say you man
gets he because I know he got a lot of
heat for the uh the controversy that was
what happened before but Hey listen
listen bro like sneako said Hey Nobody's
Perfect
nobody's perfect man so
but the prophet saws was so we're not
gonna We're not gonna say that joke bro
yeah come on bro do better
now look at him
oh you guys have no idea
you guys have no idea Rami say it as it
is bro we have a podcast coming up with
him on February 10th so stay tuned for
that inshallah
yeah 6 p.m Eastern Standard Time
Friday is Saturday all right Friday
Friday it's gonna be Friday so just me
you and Dr Ali because
oh no it's not coming that late yeah
sorry
oh
my man just said it like sorry not sorry
like
oh yes we have we have a stream without
coming up we had him on there bro
yeah we got him on already
I show speed what do you guys think of
actual speed
bro
Hamza
we already got them on bro
yeah we had him yeah
three people that we haven't had because
if if it would have been people that
we've had I would have mentioned Hamza
like the YouTuber Hamza like the the
self-improvement YouTuber because we had
them on at one point but it's like I
would love to have them on again and
just like talk more especially now that
he's been
uh I've been waking up some more things
if you can tell from the videos you've
been dropping why don't y'all get female
YouTubers
who said we don't
we've had sisters on the stream before
many many times
in their right
I wouldn't say money but a few times
I would send me a Adam yeah
come on Yo they just goes to show y'all
haven't been watching since day one
you guys Gotta Type in t3n and then plug
in the name inshallah we'll have to
leave one day Insha'Allah
yeah actually I I on my list I included
um Aiden speed and the Tate Brothers but
I think Jian is the top one as well
um if we were to extend the list to
maybe top four or five I would include
him because he did mention us on a
debate with young Don just in passing
um and I would like to discuss you know
crescendi and his beliefs with him
um
use a little bit more Orthodox he
doesn't do Christian no Pig and stuff so
no Easter I like that
that's the plan inshallah when he
thought
why does this guy always comment all in
all caps yeah man why are you yelling at
us bro
man commented again
all right guys inshallah we will be
ending this stream I'm going to check my
Instagram DMS one more time
and much to not my surprise there was no
DM inshallah may Allah bless uh brother
slingshot and guide him Insha'Allah we
will quickly go over the shahada right
now anyway regardless because uh so Rami
film I'm pulling it up anyone that is
watching this right now uh feel free to
follow along if you are ready to accept
Islam and to brother slingshot assuming
your brother please by all means you
know
watch this replay later and take the
shahada with us insha Allah uh let me
just address the last Super Chat and
then we can carry on bro inshallah
oh man there's so many comments
yes inshallah brother Bilal Allah for
always showing support
Saleem
[Music]
inshallah love that
okay so uh did slingshot snail shot huh
did he ever come around no not yet so
we're just gonna do the shahada right
now uh virtually inshallah because why
not
um where stuff is cold we're going to
reschedule that inshallah so Rami just a
quick disclaimer before we wrap this up
what is a shahada
hey shahada is what you need to do to
become Muslim to accept Islam a shahada
is just a declaration of Faith it's
saying that I believe these things
and essentially the belief in these
things make you a Muslim
right
and when we get to the translation of it
it will it would make more sense
inshallah
it's okay slingshots okay listen if you
want to accept this time if you want to
become a Muslim you just have to follow
my instructions okay there's no problem
and you can this is going to be recorded
and posted so you can always come back
to this time stamp one minute one hour
and 37 minutes
all right so and and please feel free to
check uh the description box to find our
email email us you know if we can you
can get in touch with us we can get in
touch with you because anytime someone
takes a shout out with this like every
stream we love to make a group chat get
to know them better help them out doing
some resources inshallah hook them up as
much as we can for the sake of Allah so
we would love to do that with you too we
don't want to just even leave you there
um but understand if you continue
watching our videos and beneficial
Islamic content you will still learn
more and increase your knowledge and we
make the offer that what I mean
I mean
so for a person to become a Muslim to
accept Islam it's very simple
firstly there are certain things you
have to believe or certain beliefs you
have to have in line to make sure that
your beliefs are actually compatible
with Islam and what Islam says so
firstly you have to believe that there's
only one God worthy of worship there's
only one God who created everything that
exists he does not depend on anything or
anyone
he did not have any beginning he was not
created and he does not have any
Associates there's no father there's no
mother there's no Partners there's none
equal to him there's no Sons no
daughters and uh he does not beget nor
was Hebrew God as it says in the Quran
so if you believe that that's one uh box
checked secondly you have to believe in
the Angels the angels of God that Allah
created this creation
called the Angels who have free will
and only obey him and he just you know
describes and talks about them in the
Quran
second or thirdly you have to believe in
the prophets and The Messengers that God
has sent to the world so prophets like
you know Adam peace be upon him the
prophet Moses Noah Jesus peace and
blessings be upon all them and the
prophet Muhammad peace and blessings be
upon him
next you have to believe in the
Revelation that God sent with these
Prophets You know the original Torah
that was given to Moses the original
gospel that was given to Jesus uh and
the Quran which was given to the prophet
Muhammad peace and blessings be upon him
you have to believe those as well
and when I say believe them I don't mean
that you have to open them and read them
except for the Quran you have to read
the Quran but
and I don't mean that you need to read
it cover the cover to be Muslim just you
know it's the word of God so read
inshallah you'll get great wisdom from
it but just believe that God
uh the Angels do have free will 100
percent
yeah absolutely bro are you sure about
this Angels don't have free will on
Angels don't have free will bro I'm
saying doesn't have free will but I was
like come on bro no no
because multiple people commented that
that they don't have free will to you so
I don't know maybe you said they do I
don't know
yeah I learned that they don't have free
will yeah oh I accidentally said they do
have free will I'm thinking because
multiple people commented that Angels
don't have free will they wouldn't have
probably done that oh yeah I see I see
my bad I was just that was just a slip
of the tongue they absolutely fruit in a
fruit and slip of the tongue my friend
yeah my bad one God worthy of worship
the angels that do not have any free
will that was the slip of the tongue my
bad thank you for correcting me and the
prophets and Messengers that God sent to
the world
and the Revelation that he sent with
these prophets for correcting me on that
that was a slip of the tongue you have
to believe in destiny Divine decree from
God
and you have to believe in life after
death in the day of judgment you know
the day where we will all be taken to
account for both our good and bad Deeds
if you believe these six things then you
are ready to become a Muslim and you
just have to say the shahada the
testimony of Faith which is this I'm
going to say it slowly in Arabic and
then you would just repeat after me
a shadow
n la
ilaha
Allah
bro you should start again and go much
slower than that yeah
I'm gonna repeat every time you say it
I'll repeat it yeah okay
Allah
in Allah
Anna
Anna muhammadan
muhammadan
what
rasulo
rasulu
I bear Witness
I'll be a witness that there is none
worthy of worship
that there is none worthy of worship
except for Allah
and I bear Witness
and every witness that the Prophet
Muhammad
the prophet Muhammad is the servant
is the servant and messenger of God
and messenger of God
[Music]
you are Muslim now bro comment comment
how you feel in child life you want to
um and please reach out to us somehow
we will definitely get you sorted out
inshallah we'd love to
inshallah
people got jokes bro
all right because I'm gonna head out
because it is
is about to be 11 p.m and
I must be going to sleep here
insha Allah inshallah slingshot writes
he feels great alhamdulillah
welcome to Islam brother I love you for
the sake of Allah please reach out to us
once again either on Instagram or
someone roll please bring on I'm the
winner been there done that bro come on
like what do you want in person type it
in on on YouTube t3m the three Muslims
and then put the person that you want
chances are we probably already
are you saying you want it in person bro
you want it in person that bad all right
maybe we'll make it happen in person
then
inshallah what do you want you want it
ASAP maybe we'll do it ASAP then
just let us know bro
with this being said Brothers
bro don't even say salaam I wasn't even
done yet
I hope you have a good day or a rest of
your night inshallah we'll see you soon
into us
and uh assalamu alaikum
it's okay bro it happens to the best of
us inshallah
alhamdulillah okay around me bro
anything else you want to add up before
we wrap this up uh no I think inshallah
we should be good to end it here okay
so
Rome is called looking oh nice I know
bro everybody
okay so this week inshallah we will be
streaming Wednesday at 6 PM Eastern
Standard Time and Friday 6 PM Eastern
Standard Time with Dr Ali atai I think
that's how you pronounce it right I
believe so give me if I'm wrong
um and then that's it inshallah we'll be
in person after that so a little bit of
a surprise for you guys coming up uh
yeah Romy can end up bro and with that
being said for tuning in share the
stream and like it
foreign